こんしゅうのざっくばらんな話題から始めていきます。
エーアイアシスタント育成ツールについてです。
せんしゅう、MulmoClaudeを何と呼ぶのがいいか悩んでいる、とお話ししましたが、ようやく答えが見つかりました。
それは「エーアイアシスタント育成ツール」という呼び方です。
「エーアイアシスタント」とは、わたしたちのそばに二十四時間いて、仕事や生活のさまざまなことを手伝ってくれるエーアイのことなんです。
これは、特定の仕事を人間の代わりにしてくれるエーアイエージェントとはちょっと違っています。
人間に例えるなら、「エーアイアシスタント」は秘書や執事のような存在で、「エーアイエージェント」は弁護士、料理人、庭師などに近いイメージです。
「エーアイアシスタント」と聞くと、メタのスマートグラスを思い浮かべる人も多いと思いますが、スマートグラスはあくまでエーアイアシスタントにアクセスするためのデバイスのひとつにすぎません。
実際には、エーアイアシスタントの本体はデバイスの中ではなく、インターネット上にあるということがとても重要なんです。
その実体がインターネット上にあることで、スマートフォンやスマートウォッチ、パソコンなど、あらゆるデバイスからアクセスできるようになります。
ここで頭に入れておいてほしいのが、「エーアイアシスタント」の実態は、ジーピーティーやClaudeのような「エーアイモデル」そのものではないという点です。
エーアイアシスタントが良い仕事をするためには、使う本人のことをしっかり「知っている・理解している」必要があります。
そのためには、過去の会話の記憶はもちろん、予定表、住所録、ToDoリスト、メール、ミーティングのメモ、日記など、その人が蓄積しているさまざまなデータにアクセスできなければいけませんし、その人が使っている、もしくは必要に応じて作ったアプリについてもよく知っている必要があるんです。
オープンエーアイやアンソロピックがGhatGPTやClaudeにメモリー機能を追加しているのは、まさにそのためですし、実際にユーザーのデータを多く持っているメタやグーグルもそこを狙っています。
でも、個人のデータやアプリをすべて抱えてどんどん蓄積していくことになる「エーアイアシスタント」のような大切なものを、特定のサービスプロバイダーにまかせてしまうのは、私は賢くないと思っています。
長く使えば使うほど、乗り換えるときの痛みが大きくなり、一生そのサービスから離れられなくなってしまうからです。
MulmoClaudeを使えば、「エーアイアシスタント」を自分のパソコンの上で「育てる」ことができます。
MulmoClaude自体はオープンソースですし、データは全部自分のパソコンに蓄積されていくので、そのデータも進化の方向もすべて自分で決められます。
その運命も１００パーセント自分でコントロールできるんです。
githubを使って、バックアップやバージョン管理もできるので安心です。
この「エーアイアシスタントを育てる」という感覚が、とてもたいせつなんです。
エーアイアシスタントは、完成品をどこかから買ってくるというものではなくて、自分で育てていくものなんです。
インストールしたばかりのMulmoClaudeには、何もデータが蓄積されていませんし、自分専用のアプリもありません。
そのままでは「エーアイアシスタント」の役割は果たせません。
MulmoClaudeの中で動くエーアイ、現時点ではClaude Codeですけど、これと自然言語で会話をしながら、自分専用のアプリを作って、さまざまなデータを蓄積していく ー これこそが「エーアイアシスタント」の正しい育て方だと私は思っています。
エーアイがこれからの社会でますます重要になっていくことは間違いありませんし、「エーアイを使いこなせる人」と、そうでない人のあいだには、大きなギャップが生まれるのも明らかです。
ぜひMulmoClaudeをインストールして、自分専用のエーアイアシスタントを育てて、「エーアイを使いこなせる側の人」になっていただきたいと思います。
続いて、トランプ・アカウントについてです。
少し前のメルマガで、日銀がためこんだイーティーエフをどう処理するかについて「新しく生まれてきたこどもにプレゼントしてしまう」というアイデアを書きましたが、せんしゅう、それとよく似たプランをトランプ政権が発表して、私もちょっと驚きました。
名称は「Trump Account（トランプ口座）」と呼ばれていて、二〇二五年一月一日から二〇二八年十二月三十一日に生まれたこども全員に、連邦政府が千ドルを拠出するというものです。
運用は低コストのイーティーエフに限定されていて、親や祖父母、企業などが年間五千ドルまで追加で入金できます。
基本的には十八歳になるまで引き出せず、その後はIRAという扱いになり、教育費や住宅購入などにも使えるよう想定されています。
「こどものうちから株式しじょうに参加して、資本主義の恩恵を受けられるようにする」という目的で、共和党が推進した制度です。
一方で、
政府の千ドルだけでは大きな資産になりにくいとか、
追加で拠出できる裕福な家庭ほど恩恵が大きいとか、
トランプ氏の名前をつけた売名行為なんじゃないか
といった批判もあるんですが、私は悪くない制度だと思います。
私のアイデアとは、規模や減資は違っていますが、生まれてくるこどもたちに株式を長期保有してもらうという発想は、とてもいいと思います。
ちょうど良い機会なので、以前メルマガで発表したアイデアを、note.comで
オープンレター（日本政府への提言）：日銀の保有するイーティーエフを使って少子高齢化に歯止めをかける方法
という形のオープンレター、日本政府への提言として公開しました。
続いて、エーアイ時代の働き方についてです。
せんしゅう、いただいた質問で「エーアイを使いこなせる人たちになるには、今どんな準備をすればいいですか？
」というものがありました。
多くの人が「エーアイが人の仕事を奪うのではなく、エーアイを使いこなせる人たちが、使いこなせない人から仕事を奪うんだ」と指摘していて、私も同じ意見です。
その場の答えでは、「技術職であれば、まずはClaude CodeやCodex、Antigravityを使って仕事をするところから始めてください。
コーディングはもちろん、資料作りや調査も、githubのリポジトリ上でClaude Codeを走らせて仕事をするのが、いまいちばん『これからの仕事の仕方』を学べる方法です」とお伝えしましたが、ちょっと具体性が足りなかったなと思ったので、ここで少し詳しく補足します。
まずさいしょに認識してほしいのは、すでに「ChatGPTに質問したり相談したりしている」だけの人は、世界中に何億人もいて、それくらいでは「エーアイを使いこなせる側」に立てると勘違いしないでね、ということです。
私もChatGPTを時々使いますが、使うのは調べものや文章の添削くらいで、トークン使用量（エーアイの使い方を測るのに一番いい指標です）でいえば全体の五パーセント以下です。
残りのほとんどはClaude Codeを使ったコーディングです。
もちろん、ソフトウェア・エンジニア以外でも、エーアイを単なるチャット以外の方法で活用している人はたくさんいますので、その一部をご紹介します。
一番簡単な例だと、ChatGPTに質問を投げて答えを得ようとするだけじゃなく、「壁打ち」という方法です。
たとえば、自分が考えていることを書いてChatGPTに評価してもらったり、逆にChatGPTにアイデアを書かせて、自分が評価したりする使い方です。
単なる「質問箱」ではなくて、「議論する相手」として扱うだけでも大きな違いが出てきます。
ChatGPTに資料を渡して、それを要約させたり翻訳することも、よく行われていると思いますが、その一歩先としては、資料を渡した上で、ChatGPTが先生になったつもりでいろいろ質問してみるのも良い勉強法です。
要約を読んで分からなければ、さらに質問すればいいですし、質問を深めて知識を広げるのも良い方法です。
資料をもとに質問する場合には、グーグルのNotebookLMがおすすめです。
学びたいトピックに関連する情報をいくつもひとつのNotebookに入れておいて、それらを踏まえた上で質疑応答したり、資料を作らせるのには、とても便利な環境です。
NotebookLMは、YouTubeの中身も調べてくれるので、長い動画を観る時間がない時なんかにもすごく役に立ちます。
ChatGPTやClaudeには、エーアイが作った資料を置けるCanvasやArtifactという機能もあります。
これを使えば、会話しながら人間とエーアイが協力して資料やアプリを作ることができます。
Claude Codeが生まれるまでは私もこの機能をよく使っていましたが、Claude Codeはまだちょっと敷居が高いと感じる方には、悪くない選択肢だと思います。
ここまでなら、ソフトウェアエンジニア以外の方でも簡単にできると思います。
ただ、これだけでは、これからの時代に「エーアイを使いこなす側」に立つのはなかなか難しいと思います。
ここで少しハードルが上がりますが、私のおすすめはClaude Codeです。
Claude Codeはソフトウェアエンジニア向けに作られたツールですが、Gitというソフトと組み合わせて使うことで、CanvasやArtifactでやっていた資料作りのようなことが、バージョン管理や他人との共有も含めて、本格的にできるようになります。
Gitはもともとエンジニアがソースコードを管理するために作られたソフトですが、普通のドキュメントや資料の管理にもとても便利なツールで、私もメルマガの執筆に利用しています。
まずは、Gitに関してですが、エンジニア以外の人が覚えるGitの話としては、ネット上にたくさん資料があるんです。
たとえば、「エンジニア以外が覚える Git のはなし」や、「【非エンジニア向け】宇宙一わかりやすいGitことはじめ」、それから「エーアイと働く時代のGit/GitHub入門─ 非エンジニアが『怖がらずに使う』ための20の学び」などですね。
でも、一番良いのは、ChatGPTやClaudeに「gitの使い方を教えて」と直接尋ねてみて、実際に手を動かしながら使うこと、これが何よりの近道だと思います。
Gitは、自分のパソコンだけで使うことももちろん可能なんですが、基本的にはマイクロソフトが提供しているGitHubというサービスを使って、いわゆる「リポジトリ」と呼ばれるファイルの一式のバックアップを作成したり、それを通して他人と共有するという使い方がいっぱん的なんです。
Claude Codeも、gitとgithubでソースコードを管理する人たちを想定して作られているため、実は、通常の文章であってもClaude Codeとgit、githubを組み合わせて使うとものすごく強力になるんですよ。
そうは言っても、gitで途中でくじけてやめてしまう人が多いのも事実だと思うんですけど、ここはなんとか頑張って乗り越えてほしい場面です。
「エーアイを使いこなす側」に立つための、最初のかんもんだととらえてほしいです。
このかんもんを越えられると、「エーアイを活用してできること」の幅が一気に広がって、自分自身のせいさんせいがものすごく上がったと感じられるようになります。
Claude Codeを「gitとgithub」と組み合わせて使えるようになったら、たとえば特定の会社の調査や、マーケティング計画作成、小説書きなど、どんなトピックでもいいので、自分が興味の持てる資料をClaude Codeと一緒に作ってみると良いですよ。
Claude Codeには、上で紹介したCanvasやArtifactのようなドキュメント表示の機能が用意されていないので、最初は少し戸惑うかもしれませんが、マイクロソフトのVisual StudioのようなIDE、つまり統合開発環境やテキストエディターとうまく組み合わせて使っていくうちに、その良さがだんだんわかってくると思います。
もし、「自分でアプリを作る経験をしてみたい」と考えている方には、私が開発しているMulmoClaudeをぜひ試していただきたいです。
MulmoClaudeは、先週も書いた通り、仕事や生活で必要なものを記録・記憶してくれて、いろいろな情報を調査、要約、整理、プレゼン、解説してくれる、そういった機能を自然なことばで指示するだけで付け加えられる、エーアイネイティブなツールなんです。
うまく活用すれば、仕事にも生活にも必要なあらゆる情報をパソコン上に保存してくれる、自分専用のエーアイアシスタントとして働いてくれるように作られています。
これまでは、カレンダーやToDoリスト、住所録、株のポートフォリオ管理、買い物メモ、食事ログ、仕事ログ、日記、単語帳など、さまざまなアプリをアプリストアからダウンロードしたり、そういうサービスを提供するウェブサイトでアカウントを作って使うのが一般的でしたが、MulmoClaudeなら、その手のアプリはエーアイにお願いするだけで簡単につくってもらえるんです。
なんでもエーアイに作ってもらえるとはいえ、最初はどう依頼すれば良いのかちょっと戸惑うと思うので、まずは用意されているテンプレートから好きなものを選んでもらうのがいいんじゃないかなと思います。
「コレクション」というページで右上の「プラスコレクション」というボタンを押すと、サンプルプロンプトのメニューが表示されるので、まずはどれか一つを選んで試してみるのがおすすめです。
続いて、「Tesla車を買う理由の変化」についてです。
TeslaのFSDがついに「人間の運転手よりも安全」なレベルに到達した、そんな話を先日お伝えしましたが、それがFSD、つまり自動運転機能の装着率の上昇だけじゃなく、Tesla車の売り上げにもつながっているんじゃないか、というX上の投稿を目にしました。
[EN]Something is happening. $TSLA[/EN]
よく考えてみれば、これは当然のことなんですよね。
自動車の運転って、誰にとってもけっこうなストレスですし、毎朝かよいで会社と家の往復にひと時間近くかかっている人にとって、そのストレスがなくなるだけで仕事・生活の両方にとって大きなプラスになります。
とくに帰宅するのが遅くなったときは、眠気と闘いながら運転しないといけませんから、そのメリットを考えればFSDを使わない手はありません。
FSDの利用料は月額99ドルですが、疲れているときでも安全に自宅まで運んでくれる「お抱え運転手」だと考えれば、とても安いと感じると思います。
ここ最近は、Elon Muskが大統領選でトランプ氏を支援したことがTeslaブランドを大きく傷つけたり、さらにトランプ氏が連邦政府による電気自動車向けの補助金を廃止したせいで、この二年ほどTeslaの売上も停滞しました。
ただ、FSDの価値をより多くの人が認識するようになれば、それがTesla車を購入する理由になるだろう、と長期でTesla株を保有している私は期待しています。
ちなみに私の知人で、アパート向けの充電設備を販売している人がいるんですが、Teslaの中古車がしじょうに出回りはじめたことで、アパート暮らしの若い人たちが中古のTesla車を安く手に入れられるようになって、充電じゅようが一気に増えているそうです。
こうしてしじょうに出回った中古車がサブスクリプション型ビジネスにつながっていく、こんなビジネスモデルは今までの自動車業界ではあり得なかった展開ですよね。
[EN]NVIDIAとPalantirの提携[/EN]
ここからは「NVIDIAとPalantirの提携」についてです。
先日、エヌビディアとPalantirが提携を発表しました。
[EN]Open Models, Closed Environments: Palantir Brings Secure AI to US Agencies With NVIDIA Nemotron[/EN]
エヌビディアは、さまざまな企業と次々に提携を発表しているので、この発表だけを見てもそれほど大きなニュースには感じないかもしれません。
ただ、中国製エーアイの台頭や、少し前にあった米国政府とアンソロピックの間の軋轢、それからトークンコストに敏感になりだした企業の動きを考えると、最近のAlex Karp、アンソロピックのシーイーオーの発言なども踏まえて、実はかなり大きな話なんじゃないかと思えてきます。
ご存知のとおり、今の時点でエーアイモデルの最前線、いわゆるフロンティアを走っているのは、オープンエーアイ、アンソロピック、それからグーグルの三社です。
それぞれ得意な分野はちがいますけど、ビジネスでエーアイを活用するならこの三つから選ぶのが一般的ですよね。
米軍向けなどにエーアイを活用した情報収集サービスを提供しているPalantirは、これまで主にアンソロピックのエーアイモデルを使ってきました。
ただ、実際に米軍との契約段階になったとき、武器への利用を避けたかったアンソロピック側がこうした契約を拒否してしまい、その結果、トランプ政権にブラックリスト入りする事態にまでなりました。
最近は、オープンウェイトのモデルの性能もかなり上がってきているので、将来的にはそちらへ切り替えたいと考える企業も多いです。
トークンコストの問題もありますけど、エーピーアイサービスを利用するとデータやノウハウが外部に流れてしまうというのものすごく大きな懸念点です。
しかも、オープンウェイトのモデルの多くは中国製で、中国共産党の価値観で作られているエーアイを西側で利用するのは間違っている、と考える人も少なくありません。
実際、私もその一人です。
そうした中で、Palantirは、エヌビディアが提供するオープンウェイトモデル、Nemotronを全面採用して、クローズドなエーアイモデルにも中国のオープンモデルにも頼らないエーアイサービスを米国政府に提供すると宣言したわけです。
エヌビディアにとっては、オープンエーアイ、アンソロピック、グーグルの三社が最大のお客様ですから、あまり正面から彼らと対立したくはありません。
そこでまずNemotronをさらに成長させて中国オープンモデルへの対抗軸にしつつ、同時にこの三社に頼らずにエーアイモデルをPalantir経由で米政府に提供する形を選んだんです。
アンソロピックだけでなく、オープンエーアイやグーグル社内でもエーアイモデルの軍事利用に反対する声は多いので、西側の企業であるエヌビディアが提供するオープンウェイトなNemotronをPalantirが軍事向けに使うというのは、私にはなかなか良い落とし所に見えます。
Palantirとしては、これをきっかけにして、一般企業に対してもオープンウェイトモデルを使ったPalantirのソリューションを提案したいと考えているのは間違いなくて、そこでもNemotronが大きな役割を果たす可能性がある、と私は見ています。
さて、私の目に留まった記事についてですが、Teslaがヒューマノイドロボット「Optimus」の部品について、具体的な調達目標をついにサプライヤー、つまり部品供給会社に提示した、というサプライチェーン関係者のX投稿がありました。
その投稿によれば、Teslaはサプライヤーに対して、ことし九月までに週一千台分、年末までに週二千から二千五百台分の部品を生産できる体制を用意してほしい、と求めているということです。
まずは、Teslaのサプライチェーンについてのお話です。
Teslaは、通常は二ヶ月前に発注をかけるそうですが、すでに八月分として数百台分の具体的な発注が確認されています。
このペースでいくと、十二月末までにサプライチェーン全体で、年間十万台分のOptimus部品をきょうきゅうできる体制が整うことになります。
また、この大量発注を確定する前の六月下旬には、Elon Musk自身が最新版のOptimusをレビューして承認したとされています。
これによって、三年以上の研究開発期間を経たOptimus Gen 3、つまり第三世代がようやく研究室から出て、いよいよ量産段階に入ることになるんです。
さらに、その会議の場でElon Muskは「年末の生産目標を達成できなければ、Optimusの調達部門を全員解雇する」と最後通告をしたそうです。
投稿者は、こういった強気な姿勢こそが、無難な標準的な予測よりもはるかに、サプライチェーンやしじょう、ロボット業界全体に自信を与えるものだと述べているんですね。
最近、しばらくTeslaからOptimusについての新しい情報はありませんでしたが、このリーク記事を見る限りは、計画が順調に進んでいる印象です。
初年度から年産十万台というのは、かなり積極的な数字ですが、自社工場で実際にOptimusを使って、そこで集めたデータでエーアイをさらに強化していくという計画なので、このくらい必要なのだろうと思います。
[EN]China fired a shot heard around the world[/EN]
続いて、中国のヒト型ロボットについてです。
中国がヒト型ロボットの生産と価格破壊で世界を圧倒し始めていて、「物理世界のエーアイ軍拡競争」で先行していると指摘しているX上の投稿があります。
この投稿によると、中国は二千二十五年には、世界の産業用ロボット導入の五十四パーセントを占め、ヒト型ロボットでは一万二千八百七十台を生産、世界の導入台数の八十パーセント以上を中国が占めたとのことです。
特に注目すべきは、価格の下落スピードです。
中国のロボットメーカーUnitreeのヒト型ロボットは、二千二十三年には約八万七千ドル、つまり日本円で千三百万円ほどだったのですが、二千二十五年末には約二万五千ドル、三百七十五万円ほどに六〜七割も値下がりし、さらに最新のR1モデルに至っては四千九百ドル、七十三万円ほどと、中古車並みの価格になっています。
中国がこれほど早く動ける理由として、投稿では、既存のサプライチェーンがあることを挙げています。
中国のヒト型ロボット企業の半数以上は、電気自動車や家電のサプライチェーンとそのまま重なっていて、自動車向けに作られていたモーターやギア、アクチュエーターと言った部品を、新しく工場を建てることもなく、そのままロボットに転用しているんですね。
さらに、政府の誘導ファンドがことしだけで二十〜三十ビリオンドル、つまり三〜四兆五千億円をロボット分野に投じていて、上海市は二千三十年までに十万台の工場向けロボット配備を目指しています。
この投稿は、中国がエーアイソフトウェアの競争ではアメリカに負けつつあることを自覚しているからこそ、エーアイが最終的に動かす「物理レイヤー」、つまり本体であるロボットを握ることに全てをかけていると分析しています。
二千二十五年時点で、中国のAgiBotが世界シェア三十九パーセント、Unitreeが三十二パーセントと、中国企業だけで世界しじょうの約八割を占めていて、二千二十六年には中国のヒト型ロボット生産がさらに九十四パーセント増加するとの予測もあります。
アメリカ側の対応は、まだ正式には決まっていませんが、半導体や電気自動車の時と同じく、TeslaのOptimusやFigureエーアイなどのアメリカ製ロボットメーカーへの政府の補助金が出るだろう――というのが投稿者の見立てです。
二千二十六年後半に量産開始が見込まれるTesla Optimus Gen 3が、サプライチェーンと資本しじょうを大きく揺さぶる可能性があるのではないか、と締めくくられています。
ちなみに、私は以前、TeslaはOptimusに必要な部品の多くを中国から調達しているという話をどこかで読んだことがあって、少し心配しています。
このメルマガでも何度も指摘していますが、中国に変わる「西側のサプライチェーン」を作ることは、アメリカの同盟国である日本や韓国にとって、理にかなった戦略だと私は考えています。
[EN]Syntiant files for a US IPO, betting public markets want edge AI too[/EN]
さて、次はSyntiantのアイピーオー申請についてです。
イヤホンやスマートウォッチのような機器の中でエーアイを動かす半導体を作るSyntiantが、アイピーオー、つまり株式上場を申請したというニュースがありました。
Syntiantは二千十七年に創業し、カリフォルニア州アーバインが本社の半導体企業です。
Intelとマイクロソフトのベンチャーキャピタルも出資していることで知られています。
エヌビディアのようにデータセンター向けの巨大なエーアイチップを作るのではなく、その正反対のエッジエーアイ、つまりクラウドに送らずに手元のデバイス上でエーアイを動かすことを強みにしています。
しょうひ電力が極めて少ないNDP、ニューラルディシジョンプロセッサという専用チップを、イヤホン、補聴器、リモコン、車などに、累計で一億個以上出荷しています。
具体的には、イヤホンが「ヘイ、○○」といった呼びかけの声だけを聞き分けて本体を起こす、というような常時待ち受けのしょりを、極めて低しょうひ電力で実現するようなチップです。
七月六日に提出された上場申請書類、Form S-1によると、上場先はナスダックでティッカーは「SYTN」、主幹事はシティグループ、バンク・オブ・アメリカ、UBSの三社です。
株式数や価格はまだ未定ですが、調達額は三億ドル、だいたい四百五十億円規模と見られています。
開示されている直近の業績は、四半期の売上が六千四百五十万ドルで、前年同期比三・二パーセント減。
純損失は二千九十万ドルで、前年から赤字幅が広がっています。
「エーアイブームに乗った上場だけど、足元の業績はむしろ減速している」と指摘も出ている状況です。
売上の中身にも注意が必要です。
Syntiantは二千二十四年末に、マイク業界の老舗Knowlesから、スマホやイヤホンに入る超小型のMEMSマイク、これも半導体プロセスで作る部品ですが、それを一億五千万ドル、つまり約二百二十五億円で買収しています。
そのため現状の売上の大部分は、このマイク事業によるものなんです。
同社は「音が生まれるマイクにエーアイチップを組み込んで、マイク自体を賢くする」という統合戦略を掲げていますが、マイクは利幅が小さい量産部品ビジネスであり、エーアイ半導体企業としてどこまで評価されるかは、上場審査ではなく、しじょうの審判を待つことになります。
エッジエーアイ企業の上場としては、超低しょうひ電力チップのAmbiq Microが二千二十五年七月、ウェハースケールの巨大チップで知られるCerebrasが二千二十六年五月に上場していて、Syntiantはそれに続く動きです。
一方、同じエッジエーアイでもイスラエルのHailoは、ことし六月にSPAC上場が破談となり、従業員の半数を解雇していて、明暗が分かれている状況です。
Syntiantのアイピーオーが成功すれば、「データセンターの外」で動くエーアイ半導体への投資家の関心をはかる、良い試金石になりそうです。
今後、いろいろなデバイス上でエーアイが普通に動くようになることは間違いありませんが、エヌビディアと正面から戦う企業ではなく、AmbiqやSyntiantのように低しょうひ電力を強みにしたエーアイチップを提供する会社に投資するのも一つの戦略だと私は思っています。
（私自身、Ambiqの株を少しだけ持っています。
）
ちなみに、私はエッジでの活躍を期待してQualcommの株を長期で保有しています。
業績も株価もあまり大きく動いてはいませんが、エッジエーアイ業界の成長はこれからだと思っていますので、まだしばらくは保有し続けるつもりです。
[EN]Memory-on-Logic: Re-Rating Memory Beyond the Cycle[/EN]
ここからは、メモリ半導体の評価の変化についてです。
「メモリ半導体はもはや景気循環型のコモディティ、つまりどこの会社の製品でも代替できる汎用品ではなく、カスタム半導体のパートナーへと進化している」と主張する投資分析記事がありました。
これまでディーラムなどのメモリ半導体は、好況と不況を繰り返す循環産業と見なされ、株価もそれを前提に低めに評価されてきました。
しかし筆者は、エーアイ向けメモリの技術進化がこうした前提を壊しつつあると指摘しています。
その進化は三つの段階に整理されます。
まず一つ目は、HBM、これがHigh Bandwidth Memory、広帯域メモリのことです。
メモリチップを何層にも積み上げて高速化したもので、標準規格品としてジーピーユー、つまりエーアイ計算用の半導体の隣に置いて直結する方式です。
二つ目は、カスタムHBM。
これは、顧客企業専用の回路をメモリの土台部分、つまりベースダイに組み込んだもので、業界標準規格、JEDECから離れるため、他社製品との交換ができなくなります。
三つ目は、Memory-on-Logic。
メモリを計算チップの真上に直接積み上げる方式で、中継役となるインターポーザーという部品が不要になります。
従来方式に比べて、データ転送能力は六十四倍、電力効率は三倍にもなるとされています。
すでに、SK hynix、Samsung、Micronの三社は、二千二十八年に登場予定のエヌビディアの次世代ジーピーユー「Feynman」に向けて、カスタムHBMのかいはつを進めていて、Qualcommも二千二十七年半ばにHBC、これがHigh Bandwidth Computeと呼ばれる製品ですが、その投入を計画しています。
さらに、マイクロソフトやサウジアラビアのエーアイ企業、Humainもその採用を検討中だと報じられています。
顧客専用の回路を組み込んだメモリについてですが、これは価格競争にさらされる汎用品とは違って、長期契約と高い利益率が見込めるビジネスなんです。
筆者は、いまのメモリ企業の株価は、こうした「収益構造の変化」をまだ織り込んでいなくて、以前のような循環産業としての古いやり方で評価されたままだ、と結論づけています。
ことしになってメモリ関連株が大きく高騰したものの、こんごもこの流れが続くのか、それとも近いうちにピークを迎えるのかについては、アナリストたちのあいだでも意見が分かれているんです。
わたし自身は、SpaceXが上場するときに、持っていたマイクロンの株を全部売却しましたが、このときに「これがピークだ」と判断したわけではなくて、単に「ここで売却してピークを逃してもいい」と思ったからなんです。
やっぱり、株の売り時というのは本当に難しいと感じます。
[EN]Introducing Muse Image and Muse Video[/EN]
ここからは、メタによる画像・映像生成エーアイの発表についてです。
オープンエーアイのジーピーティー Image 2にはまだ追いついていないようですが、グーグルのNano Banana 2/Proを人が評価するベンチマークで超えている点は評価できると思います。
最近は、オープンエーアイとアンソロピックの戦いばかりが注目されていて、メタはグーグルやxAIにも負けている、「番外」扱いみたいなイメージがありましたけど、これでようやく戦線に復帰した感じがありますね。
ちょっと久しぶりに覗いてみると、ChatGPTやClaudeを強く意識したメタ エーアイもかなり使いやすくなってきていて、Zackerbergがかなり危機感を持って、ここに力を入れているのがわかります。
わたし自身は、最近はFacebookもInstagramもほとんどアクセスしなくなったので、そういう意味では、メタとの距離感は遠のいた感じがします。
一番の接点はメタのスマートグラスなんですが、これも毎日使うようなデバイスではないんですよね。
[EN]NEO's Hands: An API to the Physical World[/EN]
続いては、ヒト型ロボット「NEO」を開発している1X Technologiesが発表した「腱駆動ハンド」についてのブログ記事のお話です。
このハンドは、人間の手に迫る器用さを持っていて、二十五の自由度、つまり二十五か所それぞれが独立して動くことができる、という特徴があります。
1Xはヒト型ロボットのことを「手がエーピーアイ、つまり外部との接点となるインターフェースになっているコンピューター」と捉えているんです。
従来のロボットは「掴む・置く・押す」みたいな、かなりシンプルなグリッパー、ただの爪みたいなものでしたが、手が人間並みに器用になると、こなせる仕事の範囲が爆発的に広がるというのが、彼らの主張です。
この技術面でのいちばんのポイントは「力の透明性」なんです。
従来のロボットハンドは、百対一から二百対一といった大きな減速比のギアを使っていたので、モーターから指先までのあいだで、力の感覚がほとんど伝わらなくなってしまいます。
でも、NEOの手は五対一から十五対一という小さな減速比の腱駆動、人間の腱のようにワイヤーで指を動かす方式が使われていて、ぜんぶで二十五か所の関節が力をコントロールできるんです。
しかも、外から押されると素直に動く「バックドライバブル」な構造になっていて、「動かす」と「感じる」を同時にこなせるんです。
指先には押す力や接触位置、ずれ、つまり滑りを計るタッチセンサーも組み込まれていて、物が滑りはじめたらすぐに握り直す、みたいな反応もできるとのことです。
デモでは、レゴの組み立てやネジやコインの操作、ドライバーや電球の取り扱い、ブドウや折り紙、ワイングラスといった壊れやすいものの扱いまで披露しています。
さらに、防水性があって食品に触れても安全な素材を使い、手首の関節も二百万回以上動作させるテストをクリアしているそうです。
モーターや腱は人間と同じように前腕に収められ、モーター、腱、柔らかいポリマー、触覚センサーまで、すべて自社製造で、年間一万本の手を生産できる体制とのことです。
記事の締めくくりで1Xは、「大量生産できない手では、大規模な実験ができないし、大規模なデータなしでは、身体を持つAGI、つまり汎用人工知能は実現しない」と述べています。
器用な手でやるすべての作業が、力や触覚の記録付きの学習データになる、つまり手そのものがエーアイの学習装置になる、という戦略です。
人型ロボット市場は投資対象としても注目していますし、私自身も手に入れたいと思っているので、こういう記事はとてもワクワクして読んでしまいます。
やっぱり、「手」って、人の体の中でいちばん高度なことができる器官で、人型ロボットに人の代わりに何か仕事をさせたいと考える場合、絶対に重要なポイントになります。
実は、私自身、日本の製造業を応援するために「ロボコン」を開催しようと考えているんですが、そのときには、人型ロボット全体ではなく手の器用さだけを競うロボコンにして、中小企業の技術者たちが、社長の決済なしで気軽にチャレンジできるぐらいの規模にしたいな、と考えています。
ここからは質問コーナーです。
まず、こんなご質問をいただきました。
「現在、大学院で分散システム、特にコンセンサスアルゴリズムについて学んでいます。
こんごの研究テーマを考える中で、単に既存プロトコルの改良を追うだけではなく、これから重要になりそうな応用領域や、長期的に研究する価値のある問題設定を見つけたいと考えています。
中島さんから見て、こんご五年から十年で、分散システムやコンセンサスの研究者が注目すべきテーマや応用先は、どんなところにあると思われますか？
」
このご質問に対する私の回答です。
コンセンサスアルゴリズムといえば、まず頭に浮かぶのがブロックチェーンの技術ですね。
とても良い技術なんですが、やたらと電力を消費するのが問題だし、暗号通貨をベースにしたビジネスが、どうしても全部ポンジー・スキームになりがちなのが、致命的な欠陥です。
もし自分がこの分野で研究するなら、通貨の発行をともなわない、つまりポンジー・スキームにならない形で、分散データベースを実現できないか、ということを考えると思います。
今わたしが開発しているMulmoClaudeには、複式簿記の機能があるんですけど、これを複数のマシンで並行して動かして、みんなが悪意を持っていないという仮定で、あとからgithubなどでマージする場合、どうやってマージするか、あるいはマージできないケースが出てきたときに、（人の介入があってもいいので）どうやって解決すべきか、こういうテーマはわたし自身実用的ですし、非常に興味深いと考えています。
つづいてのご質問です。
「エーアイ創薬についての質問になります。
少し抽象的な内容ですが、エーアイ創薬における本質的なお金の動きとして、『大手企業の研究開発費用がエーアイネイティブな会社に流れる』のではないかと考えています。
きっかけとしては、エーアイの登場によって創薬の最大のボトルネックであった試行錯誤のコストが劇的に下がるということですが、それがビジネス的な観点で今後登場するエーアイネイティブな企業にどういう形で売上や利益が流れるとトレンドを捉えていますか？
」
こちらに対するわたしの回答です。
理想的には、創薬の開発コストや時間が大幅にカットされて、たとえば十分の一になり、その結果薬の値段も安くなりますが、必ずしも同じ比率で安くなるわけではなく、たとえば五分の一程度という感じです。
その差額が、エーアイ技術を提供した会社にロイヤリティとして入る、こういう形がいちばんだと思います。
もし私がDemis Hassabisだったら、そういったビジネス関係を製薬会社と結ぶだろうと考えます。
続いて次のご質問です。
「このメルマガを読んでいるうちに自分でもエーアイで何かアプリを作ってみたくなった、四十四歳のおじさんです。
体重管理やオセロなど作ってみています。
おとなが楽しめるマイクラみたいで面白いですね。
質問ですが、ソフトバンクの株をいぜん持っていたけど手放した理由は何でしょうか？
アンソロピックのほうが勝ちそうな気がしたからですか？
」
このご質問へのお答えです。
ソフトバンクの株を持っていたのは、もうだいぶ前なんですが、WeWorkへの投資が失敗し、エヌビディアの株やBoston Dynamicsを売却せざるをえなくなったころだったと思います。
そんさんは、目のつけどころがほんとうに良いだけじゃなくて、こうした失敗のあとにも、しっかり不死鳥のように立ち直ってくるところが、さすがですよね。
さらに、こんな感想もいただきました。
「『MulmoClaudeとは何か？
』を読んでの感想です。
最終的に、中島さんご自身では『オンデマンドでソフトウェアそのものを生成するオーエス』と表現されていましたが、目的や価値の観点で、私はVisiCalcとの類似性をとても感じました。
最初は、
仕事や生活の中で必要なものを記録や記憶してくれることや、
さまざまな情報を調査・要約・整理・プレゼン・解説してくれる
こういったところから、『プログラマブルなノート』というたとえが浮かんでいました。
でも、さいごまで読み終えて、VisiCalcとの類似性こそが本質かなと思うようになりました。
両方とも、専門家しかできなかった『自分でプログラミングすること』の恩恵を、いっぱんの人にも開放した点が特に似ていると思います。
表計算ソフトもさまざまな用途に使われていますが、プログラミング的な側面は数式に限られていました。
いっぽうで、MulmoClaudeは自然言語で表現できる範囲が広がったので、用途もさらに広がるんじゃないかと感じます。
この、『誰でもプログラミングの便利さを享受できる』という点がいちばん重要で、ちょっと大げさにいえば、VisiCalcはプログラミング能力の民主化を実現したと言えるんじゃないでしょうか。
最近、エーアイによるばいぶコーディングが、そういった評価を受けたりしていますが、わたしとしては少し違和感があります。
」
このようなご感想やご質問、いつも本当にありがとうございます。
それでは、週刊Life is beautiful、二千二十六年七月十四日号をお届けします。
まずは、ばいぶコーディングについてのお話からです。
ばいぶコーディングは、かつてBASICなどの高級言語が登場した時と同じように、「プログラムを書く人」のハードルを下げる進化だと感じています。
VisiCalcというソフトウェアも、プログラムを書けない人でもプログラミングの恩恵を受けられるようにしたことで、本当の意味で「プログラミング能力を民主化したソフトウェア」だったと私は思っています。
そしてMulmoClaudeも、この系譜にあると感じていて、自然言語によってその対象をもっと広げて、「誰でもソフトウェアを作れる世界」に近づけているように思いました。
それに対する私の回答ですが、丁寧なコメントをありがとうございます。
たしかに「ばいぶ・コーディングを民主化する」という考え方も悪くないと思いますし、資料を作るときにぜひ参考にさせていただきます。
続いて、プログラミング学習についてのご質問です。
「中学一年生の娘がPythonの学習をしています。
Claude Codeが進化すると、コーティングそのものは私たちの仕事ではなくなり、テストすらエーアイが代わりにやるようになって、人がやる部分はかなり減っていくという話が、今週の質問コーナーでありました。
そうなると、これからのこどもたちにこの分野の勉強をさせるなら、中島さんなら何を学ばせますか？
そもそもプログラミング学習自体に意味はありますか？
」という内容でした。
私の考えですが、たしかに人間がプログラミングをする場面はどんどん減ってきていますが、それでもプログラミングを学ぶこと自体には大きな意味があると思います。
電卓やパソコンが身近なものになっても算数の勉強が不要になっていないのと同じで、じぶんでプログラミングを経験することは、エーアイがコードを書く時代になってもやっぱり重要なんです。
続いて、日々の知的生産活動のバランスについてのご相談がありました。
「私は視野を広げるために新聞を六紙チェックしたり、ビジネスやマーケティングの勉強を日課にしていますが、完璧主義の傾向が強くて、仕事が忙しい時も全部予定通りこなそうとしてしまいます。
その結果、睡眠やリフレッシュの時間を一番最初に削ってしまうのが悩みです。
中島さんは仕事やインプットで“どこで合格点として終わりにするか”の基準をどう設定されていますか？
完璧主義をやめて、健康やパフォーマンスを落とさずに、持続可能な優先順位をつけるためのアドバイスをもらえますか？
」というご質問内容です。
私の場合は、とにかく「締め切りに間に合わせる」ことを一番大切にしているので、「まずは完成度八割のものを前倒しで作る」というやり方で、余裕をもって仕事するようにしています。
なので、それが早くできないとストレスにもなりますが、本当の締め切りギリギリで慌てたりはしないようにしているんです。
八割以降の部分については、時間に余裕があれば直せばいいし、なければそのままでも、とりあえず前に進めることにしています。
次の話題は、Claude Codeの実装スピードと、人間側の確認や検査の負担について寄せられたご質問についてです。
「人間の負担が相対的に減る一方で、生産性の爆発的な向上によって暇にはならない、というお話が印象的でした。
今週号の『Life-Harness』紹介で、MulmoClaudeはClaude Codeの上にコレクションという仕組みを載せて、自分専用のデータベースアプリが作れるようになっていると書かれていたのも気になりました。
MulmoClaudeにおけるハーネスは、それ自体が価値の中心なのでしょうか？
それとも本当の価値は、そのハーネスの上に蓄積されるデータや業務ルール、履歴のほうにあるのでしょうか？
もしくは、最初はハーネスじたいが価値の入り口になり、使い込むほどに価値の中心が蓄積された情報に移っていく構造になっているのでしょうか？
」という質問です。
それについてですが、MulmoClaudeのハーネス自体にも価値はありますが、より大切なのは、その上でユーザーが作っていくデータやアプリケーションなどの集合体、つまり「特定のユーザー向けエーアイアシスタント」ができあがることです。
MulmoClaudeが提供している価値というのは、やっぱり「足場」で、足場そのものにも価値はあるけれど、その上に建てる建物こそが最終的に一番価値を生むものになる、と考えてもらってよいと思います。
続いて、アマゾンに関するご質問です。
「前回、アマゾン（TrainiumやInferentia）についてのご紹介がありましたが、長期的に見てアマゾンの将来をどう見ていらっしゃいますか？
ヒューマノイドロボット大量生産やドローン配送によるコスト削減で、eコマースの独壇場になるのではないでしょうか？
テスラやスペースXほど将来への期待が株価に織り込まれておらず、割高でもないし、将来性の割に過小評価されている気がします」という内容でした。
私の見解ですが、アマゾンほどここまで成長した企業のこれから先を占うのは簡単なことじゃありません。
でもご指摘のとおり、ロボットやドローンの普及で流通がさらに効率化されていく波は確実にくるでしょう。
そして、そのなかでアマゾンは、きぼが大きく技術力もあるので、有利な立場にいるのは間違いないと思います。
まもなくじょうじょうするAnthropicの大株主でもあり、自社のエーアイチップ開発へも本気で投資しているので、まだまだ成長する可能性は十分にあると思っています。
ちなみに私はアマゾン株を長期で保有しているんです。
最後に、「The Incredible Shrinking Transistor」の "Plenty of Room at the Bottom" という締めくくりタイトルについてのご指摘です。
[EN]The Incredible Shrinking Transistor[/EN]の、[EN]"Plenty of Room at the Bottom"[/EN]という締めのタイトルは、リチャード・ファインマン博士の講演からの引用ですね。
ナノテクノロジーというがいねんや、微細化の重要性を早くから予見したものとされているそうです。
これほど昔のビジョンが今でも通用するというのは、本当にすごいですよね。
このご指摘についてですが、ファインマン博士は私も尊敬している人の一人ですけど、こういった発言があったことは知りませんでした。
教えてくださってありがとうございます。
本当に感動的な発言ですね、さすがだと思います。
以上、今週号をお届けしました。
以上で今回の放送を終わります。
またお聞きください。